strychnine heroin cocaine blood
transfusions at one point all of these
have been used to cheat in sports
whether it's Lance Armstrong in cycling
Alex Rodriguez in baseball or Russia and
well almost everything it's been proven
time and again that athletes are willing
to gain an edge Pettit of sports using
banned substances even if it means
risking getting caught as long as they
see that as a chance worth taking the
cat-and-mouse game of dopers and the
people trying to catch them plays on so
here's the situation the International
Olympic Committee or ioc began
prohibiting drug taking in the late
1960s but because of advances in
pharmaceuticals doping has thrived since
them most popular methods include blood
doping the injections of the hormone EPO
blood transfusions are taking human
growth hormone and antibiotic steroids
Russia's Olympic track and field team
and its entire Paralympic squad has been
banned from the Rio Olympics this stems
from the revelations of runner Yuliya
Stepanova
the whistleblower who outed the Russian
program on whom Vladimir Putin called
Judas the world anti-doping agency
called for the entire Russian team to be
banned from the real games based on a
report that's in Russia's sport ministry
quote directed controlled and oversaw
the manipulation of athletes analytical
results at the 2014 Sochi Winter Games
and the testing won't stop in Rio more
than 50 athletes from Beijing in 2008
and London in 2012 were caught for
doping years later thanks to prolonged
storage of test samples and advances in
technology now here's the argument
critics of the existing system say that
the anti-doping crusade has failed the
world anti-doping agency's cash-strapped
and wouldn't have even caught the
Russian conspiracy if it weren't for a
whistleblower and some say athletes
should be allowed to take drugs that
pose no health risk on the other side
anti-doping supporters say that would
reduce sports to a profit
about cruet access to the best
stimulants they acknowledged that some
athletes will always look for a chemical
edge and say that in order to catch them
for support whether financial or
investigative is necessary